so where are we you need a bit of
imagination to see everything here so we
are in this we're here on the we are
here under the race of the of the
restaurant and the bar and you know
there in front is the is the building
for the kids for the for the Academy for
the tennis academy you know for the
annual program day is you know there is
a ability for 140 kids there so there's
rooms and behind in the lower floors
there is a school I assume they're
pretty up there yeah the supervision
building an academy of tennis skiing in
Majorca for me is not a legacy no for me
is a motivation to to keep going and the
motivation to try to to help the next
generations to become a good tennis
player the days of all the kids that's
going to be here gonna be much easier
than my days when I was 13 14 12 my
schedule was crazy because I went to
school I remembered 9 to 12 I was
practicing tennis to 12 to 2 then going
to school 3 to 5 then playing football
5:30 to 7:30 ER to seat 7 and a lot of
days going back to 10 is to 7 to 9 after
all did all of this right home I have
shower have dinner you you start to do
your homework so then you are so tied up
explain about manicure because you talk
about your hometown a lot you always
talk about it a lot because you clearly
love it here and you're never going to
leave you're always gonna be here no no
no probably what is the pull of medical
team well first up first of all I have
all the people that I love here I know I
have all the family old friends
girlfriend everybody is from is from
here no I hear is my life I grew up here
no and I get used to see my my my family
diary my cousins I have a lot of cousins
moco's things that I enjoy a lot with
them very relationship with my uncles -
and
the my sister for me is difficult to
imagine a world without having the
chance to to do all these kind of things
we're an island we have to see I love
fishing I love going to the sea that's
why I believe that if you put all the
things together my yoga is one of the
best places to live in the world I have
to ask you about your year and maybe a
little disappointing what are your
thoughts on the way 2015 during the
first five six seven months of the
season basically for six months I always
get feeling very tired every time that I
was playing every time that I was
practicing so I feel it that something
you know push me here so that nerves and
CIO's and probably the injury of last
year and produce me on all these kind of
things but the real thing and being
honest with you I I suffered this is
year for especially the special that
that months but the last couple of
months I am enjoying a game now and not
worried well my my tennis level do you
think you have to change anything I have
to change yes I have to change one very
important thing is be the player that I
I was one year ago that's the most
important change I get used to not find
excuses outside of myself so I know when
the things are not going well is myself
it's not the people who I around you
know I
very good people around me I am having a
great career with all that people around
me so if everything was great with that
people doing call that years they are
not getting worse now and you win
another Grand Slam i I don't know if I
can win an organized love I believe yes
I don't know if I want to do it let's
see if I am able to relax to control my
emotions again and to if that happens
and I believe what happens soon because
I feel much better I gonna I gonna find
my my level of tennis everyone still
talks about the big four with you
Djokovic Murray and federate it's always
you for and Murray says of the three he
has the best relationship with you he
said he's the closest with you do you
think maybe you might bring him here one
day you know he will have always there
the doors completely opened for any
moment that that that he wants to call
my with we don't want to judge him no no
he's a great guy Metro die
that's very important you know for me
it's important because I am natural I
you know and not I'm trying to be I am
honest or normally with the people that
I am talking and not trying to if I am
playing bad or if I am playing well I'm
not saying I know creating stories now
uh and Andy I think is similar I think
he is fair he he's honest and he's a
very good guy no and at the same time is
one of the player with more talent that
I ever seen